formar y aire avanzan las evacuaciones
de extranjeros en Sudán este avión de la
real fuerza aérea aterriza en el
Aeropuerto Internacional de larnaca en
chipre a bordo los primeros británicos
evacuados más de 300 pero otros 4.000 de
doble nacionalidad aún permanecen en
territorio sudanés mientras que en el
puerto de jeda en Arabia Saudita este
barco del ejército francés transportó a
personal de la ONU en total Solo este
miércoles más de 1600 personas de unas
50 nacionalidades han llegado para ser
trasladadas por mar mientras que 195
franceses evacuados ya llegaron a París
en un vuelo del ejército galo un consejo
hemos decidido enviar Esta fragata que
está en terreno y que también nos
permitirá traer de vuelta a Europa a
Francia a un cierto número de
compatriotas otros países como Marruecos
también comenzaron a evacuar a
centenares de Nacionales mientras que la
mayoría de los ciudadanos chinos ya han
sido evacuados hacia países vecinos
según Beijing y Alemania anunció el fin
de su operativo el proceso de extracción
se ha acelerado durante el frágil y
reciente alto al fuego de 72 horas un
cese de hostilidades que alivia los
extranjeros pero no a los udaneses
estamos preocupados por los precios y
porque no sabemos En dónde refugiarnos
El problema es que el peligro está entre
nosotros somos los civiles los que
estamos sufriendo
los udaneses saben que el alto al fuego
no significa el fin del conflicto los
dos bandos en guerra el ejército regular
y el grupo paramilitar fuerzas de acción
rápida denuncian mutuamente
incumplimiento de La tregua
mientras que la crisis humanitaria se
agrava el desabastecimiento de alimentos
y el empeoramiento del ya precario
sistema de salud provocan el temor de
los residentes De jartum que al unísono
piden que se detenga la violencia la OMS
advirtió que más del 60% de los centros
de atención médica no están funcionando
en la capital sudanesa